okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
today i have a special guest on my new
favorite channel actually i have wheat
waffles he runs a black pill
channel in the manosphere hello
uh lovely to have me on thank you very
much yeah thanks for coming um
would you consider um your channel
manosphere is blackpill under the
nanosphere
uh so i believe my channel's like mostly
caters towards like the blackpill sort
of audience um
if you want to call it it's like under
the manosphere i guess the manosphere
like includes
everything such as the red pill black
pills and mgtow like sort of movement so
yeah i guess it falls falls onto that
umbrella too as well
okay yeah because um i'm kind of on the
outside looking in like as a girl so
it's just
interesting to see all the different
like caveats of the manosphere
um yeah definitely so what do you like
your
overarching opinion so far like dabbling
into this community
um so i actually thought that your
channel was the most accurate one that i
could find as a girl
because there's just certain things that
i've always liked disagreed with in the
manosphere just like
from like talking to friends my age and
like i don't know just hearing like the
girls side of things um like i think i
when i emailed you i said like the men
age like fine wine argument i've
literally like
i've never agreed with that i don't know
any friends that like date older
intentionally
so that's an interesting point because a
lot of i'll definitely say mgtow
and to some extent red pill uh like
believers would
argue that men do age more like fine
wine they believe that
a lot of men reach their peak smv like
late into their 30s or even 40s
so would you disagree with that um i
mean i could maybe see the argument for
like early 30s but i think of like the
guys i went to college with and other
guys like i know like most of them don't
look better in their 30s than their 20s
so so you're saying that it is just
looks but what about the superior status
that
these men in their 30s and 40s may hold
like their superior jobs
more money like do you factor that into
account or are you just going based off
looks
um i i think it starts with looks
but i don't think a guy that's like five
four five three can really like
buy his way into the high status
okay so so height is like a requirement
so
i'm going to be quite uh nitpicky here
and just just go straight to the d-pad
for you so
what is like your height cut off i'm not
sure how tall you are but like just
going based off
um like how you look now i'll probably
guess you're about five nine five
ten i'm six foot you're six foot oh okay
so is it like a requirement for you for
a man to be over six foot
um so i would say i'm a little less
picky than most girls i'd say five
ten um but like i clearly would prefer
taller the better like my boyfriend is
six three
oh okay that's interesting so
just theoretically if a man was 510
per say like would he need to be making
up for it in other areas so like if you
said your minimum was 510 like
you need to have a better face compared
to another option who's six foot
two yeah honestly yeah
um okay that's that makes sense uh an
interesting point that you
talked about in the email like short
email exchange we had
was that both men and women
like are finding difficult difficulty in
the dating market right now
so obviously i talk mostly about the
difficulties that men face however you
also alluded to the difficulties that
women face
and you touched on the points that it
sounded like you was taking the side
that
although women have easy access to
intimacy
through uh mediums such as online dating
they are struggling
in terms of relationships so it's often
coined the term that
uh men are the gatekeepers of
relationships whether that is true or
not hopefully we'll
discuss that even further uh so like is
is that like what you was trying to
allude to like do you think pretty much
do you think there is a black pill for
women
um yes yeah i do
i think um that like a guy would there's
a certain level of like attractiveness
that he would date or hook up with but
he would never like be with publicly
do you think that for a woman
are you a woman can get a relationship
with a man
of greater looks than he is even if it's
like by a point or two
um wait sorry
sorry i think i cut out could you repeat
yeah i think you're good so
so if a let's say a woman is like a five
out of ten do you think okay
um it's possible for her to get a
relationship with a man who
is a six or seven or do you think like
she only has a chance to get a
relationship with a five or
uh somebody below her looks level um no
i think she could get a relationship
with a six or a seven
um i think she just has to like make up
for it so to speak
more than like a girl that's already a
seven does that make sense
uh yeah how would you say then it fits
the other way around so
um could a map could a man do the same
like so if a man is a five out of ten
could he get a relationship
um to the same extent that a woman can
with a with a person
two points above his looks level um i
think it's
harder for him like he has to do more
than a girl does
um so if a guy's a 5 out of 10 um he
might have to make like twenty thousand
more than the guy who's a seven out of
ten
i i don't know exactly like do you think
money is a factor yeah but like just
so you think that the money can
compensate to some extent yeah a woman
wouldn't have to do the same so what
could a woman do to
make up for it um
um i would say just like like i kind of
agree with the notion like being in
shape
you know if a girl baby has like a five
out of ten face but she has a really
good body
or um like being super feminine maybe
having like common interests or
something
so do you think that it's easier for men
or women to
uh find relationships with people above
their looks level
oh i think it's easier for women oh
really oh that's
interesting because uh it just sounds
like it contradicts a bit
to the emails that you were sending me
that uh you know you're touching on the
points that
men are the gatekeepers of relationships
no i do think men are the gatekeepers of
relationships they're the ones that
propose they're the ones that ask you to
be your girlfriend
but does that make sense yeah of course
that makes sense
but i just don't understand uh that you
said it's easier for a woman to
get a relationship with a man who's
higher
smv than a man doing the other way
around
um well when i think of like what a girl
has to do to increase her smv i think
it's like
easier than what a guy has to do to
increase his smv so a girl might have
like a five face but she could increase
her smb by
being like fit feminine and like
friendly right like i kind of agree with
that notion and maybe get like a six or
a seven but a guy has to like
work for five years to increase his
income by 20k
or like 30k whatever it is so that's
like harder to do
or um possibly like learn game increases
social status whatever it is
and i think those are all incredibly
harder things to do than like what a
girl has to do
yeah yeah okay but but i think like
but i think like if a girl is like a
five
and like wanted to get a nine i don't
really think i think that's
i don't know if that's possible where if
a guy is a five
he could become a billionaire and get a
nine but that's like
that's the my problem with the
manosphere is they talk about in screen
in extremes but like it's very rare that
a guy becomes a billionaire or a
millionaire that's not common
yeah i have two points with that i have
heard that argument quite a lot
my first point is like similar to what
you said that when we're talking about
this guy becoming a billionaire and
being able to attract a
nine despite him being a five like this
is by far like less than
0.01 of the population that is actually
going to
be able to you know attract a woman by
that uh avenue
like the majority of people aren't going
to become a billionaire or a rockstar
or a like a famous person it just
doesn't appeal to the like 99.9 of
average people so would you agree with
that
yeah i agree with you and the second
point i have this is a bit more
interesting that
when you do see these cases of a
billionaire five
uh being able to attract a nine out of
10 supermodel
would you say that like the love is
genuine like would you say that the
woman is actually in love
with the uh man or is she only there for
the resources that he can provide
um yeah it wouldn't seem to be genuine
it seems like if the money went
um she would go to hmm yeah
yeah so so she's only there for like the
resources that you can find
and what about have you ever seen the
cases of i'm not sure how much of my
content you have watched but like
observing women's body language
uh which shows that but the woman is not
actually
interested in the man so like if a woman
like refuses to like hold a
rich man's hand or something something
along those lines then
it shows that there isn't a genuine
interest there
um that's that stuff is really
interesting to me but i haven't seen
those videos
um oh okay fair enough the one the one
video i saw
which i actually was curious what you
think um
shoot sorry um the video i saw of yours
was neil strauss where he attracted that
model
yeah yeah so that's a good example so
obviously neil strauss has
a lot of money um he's arguably high
status to an extent like he's
you know a author so and he was
partially able to attract that one
because of that so would you so would
you say that that is like a genuine
level
uh well see i actually agreed with you
until i looked into it more he cheated
on her
oh really yeah i'm not aware of like the
whole situation but
like the from the face value of it like
what my interpretation was like
obviously i didn't read a huge amount of
it so i'm not sure
what to what extent that that would have
had on the relationship
or even further like this is just
speculation right now but
is it possible that the man uh neil
strauss wasn't get
getting uh his needs satisfied um
from this woman and therefore he might
have felt a need to cheat
because in all honesty if they was um
having intimacy
five times a week then i don't think
that he he may have like
felt a need to to go out and cheat um
that's a good point i never thought
about it like that
that's possible yeah yeah well like the
point i've made in the video like
obviously just looking at the face value
that um this man significantly below the
woman's looks level like ended up
divorcing in five years so when you do
see these
so-called outliers of a map being
significantly below
uh the women's looks level then the
relationships are often volatile and the
uh yeah so it usually ends up breaking
down prematurely
yeah no i definitely agree with that
that was actually why i liked your
channel so much i've never seen someone
like break down the looks chart like you
did
and that just seemed to be the most like
accurate way i've seen
like i think it all starts with looks
even for girls and guys will say that's
not true
yeah and i would say that it's a lot
harder for men to pass the
looks like barrier that women like hold
up like the standards that they hold
like 99
of the time the man is going to re
rejected
hurdle one which is looks and i think
that a lot of the time
the red pill community in particular
focuses too much on
uh what happens after you've captured a
woman's interest but i think that there
is less spoken about on
actually passing the first looks
threshold that women face
because that is where most men are
getting weeded out
yeah well i think i don't think women
care as much about like
like facial symmetry so to speak but i
think height is just so big for women
like women do not want to be with a guy
that's shorter than them so if you get a
guy that's shorter than the average girl
it's going to be really tough for him to
find a relationship
so that's going to be quite problematic
so did you obviously like you're a tall
girl yourself so would you like place
higher
uh height to a higher degree than maybe
shorter girls because you often hear the
phrase
uh you know like a five-foot woman will
say oh as long as the guy is taller than
me while i'm wearing heels
that suggests that a man who is five
foot four or five foot five
like has a chance he's is he's in with a
chance uh do you think there's truth to
that
yeah um i would say i mean i think
shorter girls when given the choice
they're gonna pick a taller guy like no
matter what height
they're at um but if i was gonna give a
short guy dating advice
i i probably would suggest he goes after
the shorter girls to have the best
chance but is his height still gonna
play a factor
yeah like of course yeah of course of
course
yeah there's amples of uh data to back
that up
um in fact i've actually got a chart
it's interesting you brought up that
point
i just found it's quite interesting
because
have you you sharing my screen right now
yeah so this like
this chart measures the number of
messages that both men and women receive
uh on i believe the dating site okay
cupid's
it might be tinder i'm not i'm not too
sure and you can see
so men receive the most messages
around six anywhere between six
one and the latter peak is around six
five
so like this is like the ideal range uh
but like
there is a massive drop-off for men
after around 5 10 like once you're below
5 10 that is when
the steepest uh shift happens but what
you notice is that when you look at the
chart for women
their height isn't really problematic
until you reach like five foot 11 and
onwards that's when like a steep
drop-off happens
but all the heights from four foot eight
to five foot ten like five foot eleven
sorry
that that is like quite consistent like
men don't see that as an issue
yeah i haven't real i haven't had a
problem um
like i've never had a guy say that he
didn't like my height
ever if anything like when i first saw
this graph my explanation for it
like the drop off would be men not would
it be willing to
approach the woman because they aren't
tall enough for her
rather than the woman being tall too
tall for him
because based on my experience like i
don't think a like a woman's height
has a significant um factor on our
attractiveness if anything i actually
believe that
women who are taller like five foot
eleven uh six foot six foot one are more
attractive
hence why there is a such high
concentration of uh those types of
models in the like industry like they're
usually
much taller but would i approach one
probably not because i'll be i'd say
that i'm more likely to approach
women in the like five foot four five
foot five sort of range or lower
because that who is like i probably have
a stronger chance with
no i definitely agree with you um i was
like because i've played sports my whole
life most of my friends
are five ten and up so i even have a
friend that's six
five that got married to a guy that's
six seven
so like i don't you say six five to six
seven
yeah see this is interesting because
i think it is even if a woman is tall
like
let's you know say six five i don't
think that she will have many issues
finding a partner who is still taller
than her like
even though it is extremely rare but for
men who are significantly
below average height like five foot six
or five foot four even
it's unlikely that they'll be able to
find a
girlfriend easily who is five foot like
she's likely still going to reject him
well and that's what the manosphere
doesn't really talk about like they act
like
any guy can just become a quote-unquote
high-value man
and i don't think it's in the cards for
all guys
yeah yeah and and obviously like as the
data
we've seen here yeah suggest that i want
to move on to something else because i
think
uh this is quite interesting so like
we've both got like a reasonably idea of
reasonable idea of where we go at the
moment what do you think of
this i came across this a couple weeks
ago i found it
hilarious what's your thoughts
i'm so lonely um
no that's real that's true i would say
uh
but i think when a girl accepts a date
with a guy she's looking
more for like a long-term relationship
or a husband where i
if a guy accepts a date with a girl i i
think they're less picky because
you know they want sex more more so than
a relationship
not not all guys but i would say like
like
you know at the end of the day if a guy
gets like late he'll go on a date with
someone you know
so what's your opinion on you know the
the good old phrase that
men are the gatekeepers to relationships
when like women
or women are getting like date proposals
and why are they refusing to date those
men
uh probably because they're not
attracted to them for whatever reason
whether it's like social status
height looks whatever it is so would
that imply that
women are the gay keepers of
relationships rather than the other way
around
because they're the ones refusing to
comply um
see that's hard because i can't say that
because men are the ones that
ask like they're the ones that get on
their knee they're the ones that
hold the key like a girl's never gonna i
would say rarely is gonna ask a guy to
be your boyfriend or ask
a guy to marry her but if we're talking
about like a genuine date like the man's
not asking for a
hookup like or anything like that i'd
say the man
like when a man asks a asks a woman on a
date
there's probably like a 10 to 20 chance
she's going to comply and say yes
yeah but i would agree so in the
like 80 to 90 percent of the time that
the woman is like rejecting the man like
that's her
in control like that's her in power and
by the definition of a date like i think
that's
implying there is the potential to have
a relationship there like
if a man wanted intimacy from a woman
then he's likely just going to ask
uh do you want to just hook up right now
i i doubt that if a man's asking for a
date
he's looking for intimacy he might be
but like not anywhere
near to the extent um
yeah i guess i could see how you could
make that argument
so so based on that like uh if women are
the if women
are the ones who are turning down date
proposals from men
like such as what this image shows yeah
yeah then
would that imply that women are the
gatekeepers of relationships rather than
the other way around
um hmm that's a that's a good point
um yeah i guess i just i have a hard
time saying that
because again like men hold the key to
marriage so that's probably why i still
wouldn't say that
um but i think with like a guys
below their league so to speak yeah they
hold the
gatekeeper to relationships so
would i be correct in saying that you're
backtracking on the statement that many
the
gatekeepers relationship but rather than
a gatekeepers to marriage
hmm yeah actually yeah that would make
more sense
so yeah that's that's a interesting
argument
but like i would say that it's less so
if a woman so if a man and a woman is in
a relationship
i think that like a woman you know like
she she's happy she's content now like
i don't think that she's gonna be upset
the fact that uh he's not
willing to propose and if anything the
man is
likely not going to want to go that
extra step and get married
because of the potential repercussions
i'm not sure how much you know about
um like divorce courts and um
like the implications of how that can be
devastating for a man's
uh financial life in particular um so so
what's your thoughts on that
um yeah i'll put a question this way so
if a
man refuses to or so so to say like
refuses by
just delaying it uh the wanting to get
married is that because
he's not um like willing to commit fully
or is it because he's concerned about
these external factors
such as um you know the the issues with
divorce
divorce courts um so i mean i haven't
i i can't really give you a definitive
answer because i don't know
i just know like what i've seen and i
have like brothers right that have been
dating their girlfriends for like
three four years and i just know that
they wouldn't marry them until they
twist their arm and make them do it but
i don't think it has anything to do with
money
i think some guys like just don't want
to commit long term
like it's kind of scary for them to
commit one girl for the rest of their
lives
i don't think three to four years is
like that um
a long period of relationship time to
expect a man to propose like
honestly i'd say most relationships
nowadays like they don't get married
until
like at least at least five maybe even
like 10 or 15 years
to consider like getting on his knee
no way
so would you say that um in fact i
watched an alexander grace video
the other day uh going over exactly this
topic
and it's strange the uh
comparison from the situation now
compared to what it was like
uh 50 60 years ago so 50 to 60 years ago
uh men like were pretty much like were
willing to get married like within the
first
year of of um forming a uh
not i think was it going on the first
day i don't know the exact uh terms of
the study but
it showed that men were much more
willing to comply
about getting married like early on
compared to what the situation is now
where men are delaying or
apparently delaying the onset of wanting
to get married they would they would
rather stay in a 10 to 15-year
relationship
before like knowing for certain that
they want to get married with a
woman were the guys having sex with the
girls before they
were married at that time because i know
if this was like 50 to 60 years ago you
said
yeah oh i'm sorry i said so
so the data basically showed that so the
basic the data is basically
showing that um men are less likely to
want to get married
um now compared to 60 years ago
and and you think that's because of the
courts basically because of the lack of
legal protection for men yeah yeah i
would say
yeah it's mainly because of that reason
i've always thought it was more because
of the development of birth control
so then essentially you're living as a
married couple without having the
consequence of possibly having a kid
i'm not sure i'm a bit confused so do
you wanna
so i'm saying like before um like my
grandma's generation
people didn't typically like live
together before they were married
um yeah so so it's not common nowadays
yeah and it's more common nowadays but
why are they able to do that because the
development of birth control
so you can have you can have like be
intimate now and not have a kid
yeah whereas before like that was that
was
in the cards like you could possibly get
pregnant um
so so is that going to intensify as men
to get married earlier or
yeah i would think it would incentivize
you to get married earlier and date a
little bit more seriously on both ends
because there's the consequence of a
possible
child like i think
yeah yeah i guess there is like a some
extent to that argument but it could be
my argument it could be an element
of both uh but like i think we'll have
to do more research in
looking into the day to see what that
has to say about it uh
i just want to move on to something else
because i found this really like
hilarious as well
i i think what when i hear people say
uh the argument men are the gatekeepers
of relationships
this is what comes to mind and i think
this sums up the dating scene
so accurately uh right now in 2021
so like we have a man of the woman right
here like what did you say both of them
just quickly out of ten the girl may be
a seven eight uh then how about
it uh how tall is he or just this
i'm not entirely sure like that's yeah
well you don't know if the woman's on
hills or anything like that but i don't
know
there's not much information here let's
just say maybe five
five i would say maybe six
okay so i would say this guy
about five to six like he's got a
narrowing lower thirds
um like he he's not bad like his eye
areas like quite good
he's got curved upper lids like his
eyebrows are too n-shaped
which like he's giving a slightly
effeminate appearance in his eye area
and of course he has a narrowing lower
third so that is why he
appears a bit softer but i was still
like he looks quite healthy his
hairline's good
uh he's his teeth are straight and like
uh
white i don't think he has that many
issues going on i i'd probably agree
that he's about five to
six like you might get i bet some people
in the comments of my videos will say
that he's a four or three but
i would say he's about five pushing six
you said that the woman was a seven i
would say she's closer to about a five
okay i would say both of these are like
a similar
sort of looks match um feel free to
leave in the comments if you think that
these are
like if either of these two people were
a couple which one you would think is
punching or
uh this is how i
um rank like um looks basically so
i i rank like body one to ten and then
uh for girls and face one to ten divided
by two guys i do the same thing with
height
in their face so one more time
so you rank like a woman's body from one
to ten like how in shape she is
yeah and you break her face one to ten
how in shape she is or like how pretty
her face is
and then you divide it by two i mean
this is just rough i haven't like
totally thought this completely through
but this is just like roughly because
when a girl's in shape that like makes
her higher up
and the guy like i do the same thing
with height
does that make sense yeah i say hi like
if i was going to put numbers on it i'd
say that like
for men it's 50 face 30
height 20 body but for women i would say
it's like
50 face 40 body 10 right
that's what i would say and so i'd give
her a seven because she looks
then like but you still like there's not
a lot of weight by her face does that
make sense
yeah i'm just looking at the comments
right now and they're mostly saying
about
five five six five okay
both yeah looks matched um yeah they're
mostly saying about five or so yeah five
six
like same as me so i i would just say
that these like both two
looks much people um and
but what's interesting is if we look at
this bit because this is like the main
point
he says we look so much like a couple
here
and then she says oh a couple of besties
so
from the situation like we have a hand
it looks like the man is
um thinking that they are both
compatible for a potential relationship
but the woman is not willing to comply
like quite evidently i think that she
has friendzoned him
so i think this is the issue with the
idea of men are the gatekeepers of
relationships because i would say
these two people who i'd say are looks
matched
the woman is withholding the possibility
of a relationship compared to the
like the other way around it's not the
man withholding it
okay yeah no that's a good point yeah
and i would say
when women are using the term um
men of the gatekeepers of relationships
they're referring to
a man significantly below her no
significantly above
sorry her level so this woman like this
is complete speculation here but
i would say this situation that we have
going on the
man probably thinks that they're a good
match like he's probably simply over her
to some extent like
he's the type of guy who's gonna pick up
her from work like
to and from work every day like just as
a favor like not expecting anything
returned like he's a bit of a white
knight
and i think this shows in the message he
said as well and the woman's probably
able to get hookups with men
significantly above her looks level and
she's probably thinking in her mind that
oh why can't i just get if i can only
just get commitment from one of those
guys
an eight or nine like if i can just get
the commitment from
that guy like the chad who's not willing
to just get the commitment from him
then i won't have an issue and i think
that is why she is friend-zoning
uh this man because of her lack of
perspective of
her own suffering yeah no i think that's
true
i've been thinking a little deeper just
now because the fact that you said
uh that this woman is a seven
like uh i would say it's quite
widespread that
women overestimate their appearance
more than men do would you agree with
that yeah i agree with that
like i watched a video the other day and
this is the guy basically said that
every woman nowadays
thinks she's a ted oh my gosh no they
totally do
yeah i don't think that's like so what
would you say that is
like what would you say the main reasons
well well when i learned like
i see it's so hard because i i see some
things in the mannosphere in real life
and i know in the manuscript they want
you to like quote study after study
after study
and i'm not going to pretend like i can
do that i just kind of compare to what i
see in real life
um so i've definitely like in college
environment scene like the 20 80 rule
where it's like 20
of the guys have access to like 80 of
the women but i've also seen girls like
simp over guys that are like
like short and going nowhere you know
what i mean
so but i compensate that with a good
face
so like take um what's that got his name
from
um twilight he's quite short
um but like he's about like eight nine
out of ten in the face and yeah women
are still like
simping over him to a large extent
because he is like
so far superior in his face
um yeah probably you're probably right
so i was just going to say like my the
reason i think that this is partially
happening is because this woman
i again this is speculation but i say
this woman overestimates her
attractiveness one because she is able
to get hookups with
men significantly below above her own
level
two on social media on instagram like
whenever she posts she's likely gonna
get
like hundreds of her you know likes on
it
and she's gonna get all of her best
mates and even a few men like telling
her how gorgeous she is
uh that she's stunning like she's you go
girl like pretty much
that sort of thing and she probably sees
the same on tinder like
she's getting hundreds and hundreds of
matches and
um she probably would reflect on that
and think
this must be uh evidence that like i'm
very attractive
yeah no that's probably true
but i would als but would you also say
that um that is true for
the majority of women
yeah probably yeah i think i think most
girls have symptoms
like somewhere in their life yeah um
yeah
i'd even say i'd even go as far to say
like 90
to 95 of women will have like plenty
of options like dozens and dozens of
options because men
are willing to date down a lot of the
time in
uh their looks level so like uh
if you take like a six out of ten like
he's he's probably gonna talk to the
three or a four uh simp over her because
he's not getting chances with the people
on his looks level
oh because they're aiming higher yeah
those girls are aiming higher
yeah i think i'm not sure if you've
heard of this other channel but
have you heard of face and lms no i've
never heard
i think he put it a i think that he
worded it perfectly he said that
dating for woman dating for women is a
race at the top
but dating for men is a race to the
bottom
yeah so it's kind of it's kind of like
just this cyclical effect i think that
we're having that
um like women so men are dating down
because they're not getting
feedback from their own uh sort of like
looks match
and then women are reflecting on that
and thinking that they can achieve
higher
and their men and then because of men
are getting um
feedback from the women below their
looks level they're then willing to date
even lower and it's just this like
cyclical effect that we're seeing that
men are willing to stoop lower and lower
and lower their standards
more and more just to um get get
intimacy pretty much
do you think that um girls when they
want to get married they end up like
finding someone on their level or do you
think they tend to marry up to
or stay single in my opinion this is
gonna sound like
a little bit bleak but i would say women
um end up marrying somebody
close or slight slightly above their
looks match
but that is not because um like she is
willing to do that it is
because a woman so say if a woman starts
off as like a six or a seven
by the time she hits 30 to 35 like she's
her looks
reduces down to like a five like that's
just the natural aging process
and then like because men age slower
like now the fives
who have built status and wealth look
more viable
and she's looking for somebody to um a
partner to secure
and somebody to potentially like start a
family with raised a child
but she spent like the majority of her
best years her youth years
chasing somebody potentially out of her
league but she's
more like more or less she's waiting for
her looks to decline and then
realizing that she's not got as many
options as she once had and then she
might be willing to settle a bit more so
i think that that would be that would be
for women that get married older
right would you say the average age of
marriage is dramatically increasing
i don't know the exact numbers again but
it's 27 yeah it's 27.
you're sure 27
it's 27 for women 28 for men um
according i just googled it the last
time probably in the last month
um i didn't double check triple check
the source or anything i just figured
that's probably right
so if you find something more credible
with your [ __ ] first
first marriage first marriage
fifty percent of marriage has ended
divorce and most people get remarried
after that
so i'd still say there's a large chunk
of women who maybe
um settle early with their first
marriage
have a child like split up after a
couple years and then get remarried with
um somebody lower smv uh in their mid
thirties
because i don't think that's ignorable
because there is such a large portion of
women that are getting married
older uh no divorcing which
would in turn cause them to uh
be thrown back into the dating pool in
their mid thirties
huh um oh you're right and eighty to 90
percent of women initiate divorces which
is something i did not know before
i think it's 80 i think it's 70 percent
of divorces are
initiated by women oh is that i heard 80
percent
yeah 70 to 80 i think it's depending on
the country as well like
i live in the uk so i believe it's 70
but but even so like the point is uh
that women are the ones not getting
satisfied in
their marriages
because otherwise yeah so they're the
ones who are initiating it they're the
ones who are not happy
uh and yeah wants a divorce
sorry did i cut out again yeah yeah
i have nine siblings the wi-fi here can
be rough um
it sounds quite loud it sounds like
somebody's uh blurring out their
rock music or something in the
background i can't tell if it's just um
oh it might be like the the ac or
something i don't hear about it yeah
yeah i do see some like i do hear some
um
like continuous um
just like mumbling or whatever i don't
know what it is just yeah it might be an
ac
yeah probably yes did you have anything
else to
say on this no this is an interesting
perspective because i've never thought
about it that way that women actually
in some in a lot of cases do hold the
gate
like the access to relationships i just
never thought
about it like that yeah i was just going
to bring up
another case study for the other way
around uh
literally further portrays what i'm
trying to say like
um i find this hilarious as well uh if
you've never seen it before
this is like gold uh so this was pasted
posted to facebook um some young
maybe woman in her 20s who quite
obviously like has some
form of uh disability and let's just
have a look at it so
my graduate my graduation photo with my
wonderful
friend travis and then if we take a look
at the
comments we are just friends
somebody else commented beautiful couple
and she she
needs to say she needs to clarify that
we are just friends
so what's your thoughts on this
he's in the friend zone yeah yeah
like again this is like speculation on
my part but just looking at him
the way he's holding her like his big
smile i would
i think it's implied that he probably
wants to get into a relationship with
this woman like
it's quite obvious and evident like they
are looks matched you know
yeah and so like he probably wants to
get in a relationship with her
he thinks that he's she's the perfect
match for him um
but she is not willing to come comply
now moving on to the
second all right you're just gonna make
a point so your your point is that women
are a little bit delusional
women are women are wanting to date up
in
terms of their relationships this is why
i believe that women are often gay keeps
their relationships because it's
them rejecting their looks match options
and want and doing in doing so like
they're wanting to do it because
they feel that they can achieve someone
higher in a relationship and
moving on to the next part like this
coincides with like my point so
this is a few weeks later she posts this
everyone has been asking me if i have a
boyfriend
and yes i do this is him and we have
been dating for 16 months
say hi to robbie the other photo is of
my very first kiss and it was on my 18th
birthday
yeah so i just found it like hilarious
like the comparison here that
she's a so this man is in like a similar
boat
to what the guy i showed a couple of uh
you know about 15 minutes ago that he
cannot get
a relationship with somebody on his
looks level like what would you say this
guy is
he's quite young but um maybe
six i'd say about five
maybe i think people in the comments
again is gonna say four
i wouldn't write him higher than six he
is quite young he looks about
20 years old like he hasn't got many
developed features but he he still looks
healthy overall i'd say about
five yeah i'm just gonna stick with five
and he's
probably not getting results from women
who
are on his uh yeah yeah
particularly like relationships um like
he's not able to date
uh for relationships women on his level
so he's choosing to
um get a relationship with somebody
below his level
yeah know that that makes sense okay
okay i don't i don't think i'm good at
ranking people because everyone keeps
telling me i'm wrong
oh really yeah uh
wait i should have i've got this chart i
had so oh okay
you might have seen it in my most recent
video so what are your thoughts on
the accuracy of these ratings would you
say
is there any disagreements you hold
obviously like in theory you would be
more educated
in ranking men
as compared to um like obviously
probably give the guy
the five in on the top i'd probably give
him a four
wait which one that one yeah your mouse
is over oh him he
yeah he'd give him a four yeah
everything everything else so you think
this guy's a seven
these guys are like eight to nine sort
of range um
yeah probably yeah that's
yeah how do you feel about the female
rankings
is there any disagreements again
[Music]
um sorry i know i cut out again i'd say
the girls are pretty accurate
um i'd maybe give the five
it's funny because i think this is
probably gonna
go with what you like guys would say
about girls that girls rank each other
higher
i'd probably give the five in the middle
one up and give her a six
you give wait which one do you not the
bottom the bottom one i just
i'd keep but the top one but this one
you'd say is potentially a six
yeah but other than that like yeah i'd
say these are pretty accurate
i want to see what the audience has to
say um
if you're watching this right now like
leave in the comments if you think
there's any like disagreement so
just say like top six is actually a four
or
something like that if there's any
disagreements that you have then feel
free to leave that in the comments
uh but back to this like would you say
overall like this is
fairly accurate in terms of ratings yeah
i mean it doesn't put height into play
but yeah oh yeah of course yeah so okay
now let's yeah so let's let's delve a
little bit deeper into that so let's say
that this guy who you rated a four
if he was six foot two would that bring
him him
up to a six or seven or like yeah
yeah okay how about if
somebody on the lower echelons like
would their height make up for it so
this guy
if he was six foot four would that
still like would that bring him up to a
five or would he still be a two because
he's lacking in the face uh
i'd probably bring him up to like a
three or four i would say
oh so so do you think that height has a
lesser impact if you're
lower than the lower in the look scale
because there's more
there's more prevalent issues at hand i
think that it affects like
average guys if an app like if an
average
looking guy was tall i think he'd have
more options
than like a more of an increase in
options than if like a two
was tall yeah i agree with that that
makes sense
yeah yeah i agree with that point so
earlier i said that looks is
50 face 30 height 20 body for men
but obviously if you're in like the
lower echelons of attractiveness
then like because your face is holding
you back the most
like your face is going to be like 80 of
the equation like because
being frank like if one of these guys
was
six foot two six foot three or five foot
ten like it's not gonna make a
difference because
there's such more greater issues that
that need to be um
resolved first before they can climb the
attracting scale
but then for these like guys in the
middle like if this guy was say six foot
three then that is gonna be a huge
advantage
potentially bringing him up um maybe
like at least one and a half maybe even
two points
in terms of like overall rating
yeah no i'd agree with that so how about
body then how do you feel that that like
fits into the equation so if this guy
was um like ripped lean i think that
would bring him
i don't think girls care that much about
body
so would you like it maybe like
it would maybe give him like maybe from
a five
to a 5.5 or a six but i don't think body
helps that much
so based on the percentages that i have
mentioned earlier so 50 phase
30 heights 20 body like would you change
those
um i'd maybe do 40 height 10 body
well because like if you're heavy i
think that brings you down a lot but i
don't think getting jacked
brings you up that much does that make
sense oh yeah so as long as you're like
um
average build like you don't need to be
a six-pack ripped but
yeah as long as you're like not
significantly high body fat percentage
then
then um like other things such as price
and height it's gonna
yeah um but i also don't
even like if you're heavier i don't yeah
but like that would kind of make sense
with what you're saying i don't think
girls
like care as much as guys about
a happier guy about a sorry what sorry
like a heavier guy oh
oh seriously i i would say it's the
complete opposite
i i completely yeah i disagree with that
point like quite significantly
i would say that um men are
discriminated
way more for being overweight high body
fat compared to women
um how big are we
talking i think it's the question um
okay i think i've got
right
um so the guy on are you still sharing
this screen because i'm not sure
okay so the audience will be able to see
what we're looking at right now so i
would say
um the guy on the right like
he is very unattractive like he's gonna
get rejected on his body
purely because of his weight meanwhile
are you like this woman
would still be considered attractive not
as potentially as attractive like as
these two people but
a lot of men would still like feel that
this is acceptable but i think this is
unacceptable
as a man would you agree with that or
would you say that if this man is
like his face is naturally going to be
like capped at
six maybe even five purely because of
his higher body fat because it's gonna
be a lot of fat in his face
but like if this guy had good height and
average face like the five would you
consider this man
date worthy or if you still if if you
had a good personality yeah i think it
would be date worthy
no no no okay
no no no no i'm sorry you're
what i mean by personality is basically
social status what i mean is i see funny
guys
pull hot girls all the time yeah like
like you can't deny that like comedians
have hot girlfriends all the time
yeah again like i'll start off by saying
that
uh i think your credibility to the a lot
of the audience just went from like
very high to drop dropped to like quite
low
but i was just going to mention the
point you said earlier that um
again like you mentioned these comedians
who are able to attract women
yeah this is talking about like the 0.1
minority like how many guys actually
become
comedians rock stars okay if you're the
average guy you're right
yes
yeah i'm tempted to just look at a look
at the comments right now i just want to
hear what they're saying
uh after you pulled the can you see them
you should be able to see
right no i'm sharing the screen oh yeah
yeah you're right okay so i'm guessing
if i
go to my uh go to the stream watch the
youtube video then
they won't be up won't be able to uh see
what's your turn on the screen yeah
i'm not sure um she can't be serious
social status
you mean like the president right is it
showing
the stream right now or is it showing um
my
powerpoint slides no it's showing your
powerpoint i just can see
um with the app we're in like on the on
the far right hand side you can click
comments and you can see them
while we like are going oh that's good
then so if i can
read the comments then um but i'm still
showing the powerpoint slides
then that's ideal yeah it sounds like
you did get a bit of backlash um
there's a lot of uh triggered people in
the comments
yeah well when i i just see funny guys
like they're still able to get
girls that's what i mean but you're
right they're probably in the top like
90.
top top 0.1 yeah of being funny so i
could see what they mean by that
yeah so going back to the original point
then um
so would you so you started off by
saying that being
high body fat percentage is less of an
issue for men as compared to with women
so would you like to elaborate on that
further less of an issue
but what i mean is i think of like i was
thinking in terms of being funny like i
don't think being a funny girl gets you
any points and like smv
i don't know i wasn't i wasn't talking
about uh funniness or um
but that's what i'm not talking about
like being overweight
yeah being high percent body fat because
i i'm not
they said that like i'm not entirely
sure but i believe you made the case
that
um weight gain isn't as big of an issue
for
men as it is with women yeah is that
correct
yeah that's what i do oh so so um sorry
is that what you believe like would you
like to elaborate on that further
um no cuz i think you just proved me
wrong i'm not gonna
yeah thanks for being modest okay
okay thanks for being modest um yeah
okay so i'll just i'll carry on like
i'll just elaborate a little bit further
on this but then we'll
move on to something else so i would say
the baseline
actually no not the baseline the the
desired
um body for men is this
the guy on the left like this is what
like 99 percent of women they're gonna
find
the most ideal um
yeah yeah and then but and this is
okay but it's still um
like a lot of women will see this is
like somewhat of a drawback like they
i'd say women would find this all right
especially if he's compensating with a
lot of height and face
but like obviously i'd say still this is
highly desirable as opposed to this
okay yeah but then for women
wait gone i was going to say in general
yeah
yeah like from our last year
because supposedly like you're supposed
to be well you're the one who
finds men attractive so you should be
able to speak on this quite accurately
like would you
if a man had a body like this but he was
like seven
seven point five in the face or maybe a
little bit more with
six foot free hyatt would you see this
as a reason to reject him or would you
find that this is okay
no that's fine if he's taller yeah but
then it would be a bonus if he if he had
this then you would see that as like a
little like maybe a little boost like
0.5 to an extra point
um yeah maybe but like to me that that's
not that important
okay uh and lastly like so say if the
same guy
was if he was like a six in the face but
had this uh body and he was still
six foot free like would this be a
reason to reject him or
no um not for me no
oh so you would actually find this okay
yeah that'd be fine how about other
women um
would you say other women would be like
significantly turned off on this like
would
would they be able to imagine this guy
on top of them in bed
i mean i think it depends on how big
like the girl is
so does that make sense so like the girl
is bigger than him
probably like so if a girl had that if
the girl had this body
uh would she see this is unacceptable
like a big one
in general i would say no uh
but in your personal opinion you don't
uh believe that this is as much of an
issue
if he's compensating with like
heightened phase obviously yeah
true okay okay that's fine um
okay so now moving on to the but i think
i'm a lot more like realistic
than like other girls so oh no
i think you're gonna get i think you're
gonna get in the comments again um
people are gonna be like oh
she just pulled the um i'm not like
other girls
yeah i'll have a look no okay but this
is what i mean like
i've had like done like um
have you heard of like photo feeler like
where they like literally
like i've done stuff like that so i'm
not like
you know i i don't i don't think most
girls seek out that information
so do you think you have a more
realistic approach to attracting yes
as compared with most women because well
yeah because i i understand a little bit
more like i think if most
girls knew the 2080 rule like they would
move a little bit differently
you know yeah okay yeah that uh that
makes sense
um now moving on to the women so
what would you say most men would find
like the most desirable so she had to
put numbers like what would you say so
if for this like if we went one two
three like what would you say is for
this um i'd say the girl in the middle
is probably the most desirable
the left than the girl on the right i
would say probably
joint first again people watching the
video like uh
you feel free to leave in the comments
what you think i would say joint first
but this is like significantly less
attractive
but these bodies are like both i'd say
eight plus
maybe nine um but then this
four yeah um
so the comparison that i tried to make
in the video
was that so we oh so these two got
people on the left
um both lean both low body fat
percentage
the two people in the middle um again
like average like we're talking about 15
to 16 body fat
but the interesting point that i was
going to make is that
this is highly acceptable like 99 of men
are going to be uh highly accepting of
this figure but i say
um the majority of women they might not
necessarily see this as a reason to
reject a man especially if he's got the
height and face to compensate but
still most women would prefer this body
the vast majority of women would prefer
this body over
over uh this one yeah i agree
but it's not a huge factor like i still
i still stand with the thing that it's
only like 20 percent of the
equation because higher place is gonna
have more of a
more of an impact yeah i agree with you
so going back to women what would you
say like the percentages are for
them based on your experience
um like for what guys look for in women
yeah yeah um
maybe
like 20 percent
other like including everything
so not just looks are you doing like the
whole thing
yeah i'm including everything okay did
you not want me to
um i was gonna i was implying like just
the looks first and then
maybe we could have asked you that's
actually right yeah we'll ask both
questions so
first just looks like in terms of height
body face what would you say
oh hi body face okay um for
i would say it's like maybe 10 height um
body or face 50 percent 40 body
maybe yeah i'd say similar percentages
actually
i'd say maybe 60 face 35
body five height like heights almost
irrelevant for yeah
most women unless like you're on the
extreme
echelons of either end like because
obviously like if a woman is
like four foot ten or shorter than that
then
a lot of men would perceive that as um
less attractive or lower status likewise
if a woman is like six foot two then
um not they might not necessarily find
her less attractive however they
might find her less approachable if that
makes sense
no i agree i mean i've seen too many of
my tall
like six foot plus friends have no
trouble finding boyfriends as long as
they pretty face
so like i don't think height is a big
deal
in your experience would you say um have
you ever had women like complain
that the height is a factor that um like
because of like one of your friends who
is like six foot
two or something does she ever say like
oh i barely ever get approached because
of my height
but women who are short much shorter
than me like they have it easy
have you ever heard of that no um i
would say if there's any complaint it's
just
if if we were shorter like there'd be
more options that we'd be attracted to
but um does that make sense
yeah so again you're saying that yeah so
again like you're saying it's
you seeing other men as inferior rather
than the other way around
yes correct okay so yeah we've
spoken quite a lot about this so going
back to the other question i was going
to ask her
so for women including everything so
including
money including looks including
personality including
like all parts of the equation what
would you say you percentage-wise like
makes up
a woman's smv wait sorry you said money
personality and looks those three
i was just like listing off various
things but like if you have more things
to include
so if you think that a um like a woman's
having a low
uh counts if you know what i mean i'm
not
i'm trying to put it in as sensitive
personality i just put that in other
like personality femininity low body
count
i'd maybe give that like 20 to 30
percent
maybe 30 percent um looks
i'd say 50 yeah
sorry what was the third thing i forgot
money oh my oh money
i'd maybe do okay 50 looks 40
like personality 10 percent money or
personality femininity
etc yeah yeah but then like money's
quite irrelevant so it's
it's yeah would you say different
differs for men that um
money is a bigger factor for for men as
compared with women
um yeah i would say it's a bigger factor
for
men or like before women looking looking
for a man i think
but i don't think it's as much as
everyone thinks because i don't think a
five-five guy can just get money and
then pull hoes left and right
i still think money is temp i'd say
money is like 10 for both
men and women but the bar is set so much
higher for men
uh than it is for women so like if a
woman's working a
minimum wage job at starbucks like she's
just the
one of the uh you know behind the
counter workers there i don't think
that's
much of an issue like men are still
going to be hitting on her like
so easily like they're not going to find
that a big deal
but for a man like although it's still
10 of the equation
like what if he's working at starbucks
especially at the age of over 30 where i
say money actually comes
more into a play then that's kind of
seen as embarrassing
like women don't see it as attractive
you know they think that it's a bit
like why is he still working these
minimum wage jobs when like
he should have established a career or
uh
might be on the right path by this point
yeah i would say it's more embarrassing
for like guys care
or girls care more about that and
looking for a partner but you're saying
like the overall like
standards are just like higher
yeah so the bar is going to be higher
for everything
uh for men's a bit for men to be seen as
attractive so
you're going to need um you're going to
need good face you're going to need
good body you're going gonna need good
height you're gonna need good money good
job
good status social circles everything
but
for women to be seen as attractive by
men like they need to be
like past a certain looks threshold
which
i still say is like quite low like maybe
four um
obviously depending on the man's looks
as well um like maybe four
and then as long as she's reasonable in
a like personality like she
is quite feminine um reasonably low
count then the majority of men would
see that as a like very ideal option to
date
yeah i could see that um
what else do i have yeah no i definitely
think women have like a million things
that they want
where men have just like a couple much
more compact
yeah yeah so going back to like the
original question
that we were speaking about um does that
make it harder for men to get
relationships with women
or is it still like men who are the one
restricting relationships
um i don't know when you put it like
that i could definitely
i would say it's harder for the average
guy to get a relationship than the
average girl
yeah but a lot a point that a lot of um
people in the um pink
pill movement that's like the black pill
equivalent for women
they argue that they're not satisfied in
uh like if you're an average woman you
can't get the relationship they
necessarily want so they only their
options
are like these average tier guys um
and they don't want them they can't get
the relationships with these guys good
height good face good body
oh so so they're like mad that they
can't get their relationship with them
um
yeah it is i was like it's not a major
point i was pretty much just
some uh trying to sign out like with
this yeah that's what i think this
explains
um so if we look at
the wider picture actually before we go
to that um i just wanted to go
back to a point that we touched on a
little bit so
when it comes to aging like fine wine
because i've heard this point made in a
previous uh stream
do you think that the percentages change
for uh
the importances for men as they age
and what they look for as they age no in
what women are looking for
uh so yeah so there's a big argument
i've heard been being made is that once
men reach their
30s or definitely 40s
is that status and money
uh increase in importance
but meanwhile for yes so like based on
my experience like
i'm a lot younger than a lot of my
audience members but based on my
experience i would say
all throughout high school things like
that money and status didn't
really carry that much of an impact
because when you're a teenager or in
your low twenties
it doesn't really matter if you have a
low paying job or
something like that or if you're low
status women like looks
is pretty pretty much like at least
eighty percent of the equation there
and money's going to be like less than
five percent but once you're
but the arguments are being heard made
especially by men
in their 30s is that once you reach over
30 then
looks drops a little bit to maybe 50 60
and then the rest is mostly about your
status and money
um so is it sorry i'm just trying to
think about that for a second would you
say that's for attracting like women in
their 30s or younger women
yeah yeah so age-matched um women
age-matched women um i would say when
women
get because i'm trying i'm thinking of
like my sister
um for like this is who i'm thinking of
um like she married the
the guy who like looked good but then
they ended up like divorcing because he
wasn't a good husband
so then like the second time around like
she found a guy that was a lot more like
dependable and like kind
you know oh so as she aged or after she
got divorced she
was then more lenient on looks and then
she looked for
um money and status more yeah
um but i don't think that like
22 to 25 year olds are
dying to date these 35 to 50 45 year
olds like
the kevin samuels of the internet seem
to think
that's that's what i mean because that's
like the highest
you know i would say would you say
that's like the highest for girls or
maybe 19 to 25.
i'd say 19 to 25 year olds are mainly
looking at the men
in their low to high 20s i think
like 30 is almost like as much of a
death sentence
um as it is for women in terms of like
the drop
drops in smv oh i don't think so i think
um it's more 40s for men or late 30s
so you'd say that um men
so men get worse so both men and women
get worse
as they age but it gets like the the
differences in drops are much
more severe for women so men men um
like still maintain a bit of their
chance but
women's like plummet faster
um well i think women have more options
overall
so i think like if they're they're going
to drop from what they once were
does that make sense but overall like
the average guy isn't
going to have that many options in
general yeah
i think that's a good way of putting it
because it was similar to what i was
going to say so
i think yeah so if a woman goes from 20
to 35
she's probably gonna go from like 500
options
down to like 30 options but for a man
it's going to drop to like three options
down to one option
yeah yeah um i wish i had a
like another similar thing to like one
of these images like
it explained it perfectly it was some
tinder experiment some guy did
uh and the woman at hand was like in her
60s or something and she was still
getting
plenty of matches but like obviously
like nowhere near as much as a
like a younger woman would like a woman
in her 20s
like the drop was significantly severe
but i'd say for men like they're going
to go from like
five matches per month to to like
zero matches by the time they're 60.
well and that's why because i remember
being
21 or 22 and going on a date with a guy
that was 32
and just thinking oh this is so weird
he's so old
and so that's why it really confused me
when i hear about all these young girls
that are apparently like chasing
45.
uh where did i cut off at uh you was
gonna make i believe he was gonna make
the point that
um like the
the cut off um is
no yeah yeah no you said about like so
when he was dating a man
who was 10 years older than you when he
was at 21 you believe that was
strange weird unacceptable but you had
doubts in your mind
and then that's what happened yeah but
that's what i remember like
thinking that was so weird and being
like less into him because of how old he
was
um but i think after the age of maybe
like
25 ish it's like age becomes
less of a factor for women but that's
also when
they start to like drop in their smv
yeah at what age would you say women
reach their peak
attractiveness in men's size
um maybe like 23 24
um yeah actually younger
like personally i was going to say
personally like
i think most of me and my friends peaked
at like 19 if i'm gonna be honest
yeah because you go to college so
there's a lot of like unhealthy
decisions you make
in college um but
and like i don't know you start to see
wrinkles a little bit at like
21. 20 on it yeah
that's when i noticed my first like
crow's feet to be honest i was small
like barely a man wouldn't notice it but
girls do we noticed that kind of stuff
geez wrinkles that would be ringing
alarm bells if
that was me because if you think getting
rid of
21 what's it going to be like when you
reach 30 like it's gonna get
exponentially worse
and i'm someone i don't even go out in
the sun like that too
like i literally avoid the sun but oh my
gosh all the girls are like tan and
stuff they're gonna look so bad when
they're old
you think that tanning is a detriment to
a woman's attitude oh i know it is
every no no um it makes them look better
in the short term like a girl that tans
but um long term that it's so bad for
your skin
every dermatologist i've ever been to or
anyone that like takes care of their
skin or looks good at an old age they've
all said sunscreen stay out of the sun
okay yeah fair enough that's an
interesting point
oh what was i just gonna go back to yeah
yeah yeah um you said that the
peak attractiveness age for women is 24.
i would say that it's slightly lower
than that i would say about 21 but there
might also be other factors at play so
obviously if i like men see women
younger likes particularly younger like
even
19 20 21 because they believe they're
more pure
like there's also an element of that
like they're much less likely to have a
higher count combat so the woman who's
24 years old might not necessarily be
less attractive
less physically attractive because the
age-related
effects of um reducing attractiveness
haven't
really kicked in that much but i think
there might be other factors at play
such as
um more purity having a lower count
things like that yeah
so i see younger women is more innocent
yeah no i mean i think the real drop off
is like
i like feel like women slightly decline
until maybe like 27
28 where it's like slightly less and
less every year but i think around 30 is
when it becomes more steep
yeah yeah i agree with that like they
drop off after 30 like is exponentially
bad
so it's going to be fairly flat like
you're probably going to like let's say
20 years old you have like 100 of
attractiveness at 25
it's going to go to like 95 at 30 it's
down to 80. then by the time
you hit 35 it's 50 40 is like
30 so like just it just lowers and
lowers faster and faster and faster
as like women age more yeah i guess it's
downhill from here
yeah the last point i was going to make
before i move into something else like
how do you think
height ties in to this aging uh
like sort of thing so does hype become
more important as
um a man ages like the women more
looking for the six foot
two guy as they go over thirty like i've
heard that argument been made a few
times
um i mean i think the older women get
like the more they try to
actually get what they can actually get
like when they want a ring
they kind of start to shop a little more
realistically so that's why
like they might you know say okay
whatever height can go as long as he has
this this and this because she can't get
everything well so you think it
decreases um like
the importance of height decreases as a
man as a man or woman ages
so she's gonna be less because yeah i
mean i think the older women get they
get less picky because they want to ring
oh fair enough yeah i was just like i
was more so alluding to the point
but i've heard it in a couple of the
comment sections on my on my videos that
like when a man is like 16 17
and the women are 16 17 in high school
like they're not really concerned about
height as much
like they're also just looking for a
pretty face it's like if a man is like
five nine and he's
got a really attractive face like he's a
uh you know like
harry styles like typeface justin bieber
like you know the
have you have you ever heard of the term
pretty boys yeah sure
yes yeah yeah so so that they're not
really concerned about
uh height as much they're more concerned
with
um a good face with like a
really luscious like healthy looking
hair with a good hairline
like um so how do you know what do you
think
you said that your songs have changed um
over time yeah consid compared to when
you were a teenager
to what you want now oh my god nobody i
didn't date when i was a teenager
um like i i'm trying to think i mean i
would say yeah
a little bit um
yeah i would say like
i mean when you're in college it's not
there's not really anything
to do with career or success because
nobody is successful or career driven
you know but when you're post college
you kind of look at that a little bit
more
oh so status of money does like increase
in importance after
college i would say yeah would you say
and would you
um so that your standards like change
more because the general idea that i've
often heard in like the blackpool
community is that
women go for the pretty boys in their
teens in high school
but then once they turn like 22 23
they think they they look back on
themselves and they think gross why
why did i think that guy was attractive
like he's way too
cute he's like not masculine he's not
attractive and
and their standards change the more like
uh the chad
the chad uh type so like
you think women's standards get like
higher the older they get
no not higher but they change from a uh
i'll share the screen again um okay
so oh do i have an example
okay i don't have an example of like
so like right so yeah so say if this guy
was
an eight like let's just say that he was
a lot more attractive like he's a bit
feminine in the face so women are more
attracted to this guy
if he was if he was an eight in their
teenagers and then they
turn more to these guys uh who are more
masculine like
menacing looking uh when they're in
their mid twenties
um but then they go for like more the
harry styles type uh
in their teens uh when they're um
you know like in high school age um
i don't know my so what was your
experience
my boyfriend now i i would say like i
have a similar type that hasn't changed
all throughout your high school uh
college period
um from college to now yeah i would say
i have a type that hasn't changed
oh i didn't i didn't date in high school
yeah like though
when he was watching movies tv shows
like was there
like any particular uh guys that like
you know
you you dreamt of like you're like oh i
want this guy to be my
future husband oh he's so dreamy like
you know like
you know what i'm trying to say like
yeah yeah um trying to think who was
my i always liked the guy from um
what's it called what is that show
called grey's anatomy i forget his name
uh but yeah he was probably more like
feminine i would say
hmm okay yeah so so he does line up
there is like some truth to that claim
that i hear i guess but
he still probably would be my celebrity
crush like if i had to pick one
even even even now even now yeah yeah
um oh so that's interesting so maybe it
hasn't changed as much
um i want his stream to be like one and
a half hours long so
if we maybe move on to like the last uh
part
that you suggested at the beginning um
you said that you wanted like more of an
interview
type uh
sure um i just wanted you to like
explain
the black pill to me in like layman's
terms because i think i'm pretty
familiar with red pill
and i think i got some of that from this
interview like so far but i didn't know
if there's any points
that maybe we missed and we didn't go
over okay
yeah yeah that's fine um first like
what's your take in a red pill then like
what do you think the red pill stands
for like what are their main
tenets or beliefs um you can base it's
basically how to become a high value man
if i had to like put it in layman's
terms
and women don't like nice guys it's like
the red pill
that women like the chase they like guys
that don't want them
um and they also go for chads
so yeah it's a lot of guys that are
really
upset that women basically go for chads
get ran through
and then try to go for um they call it a
beta later
do you think that's what the red pill
believes the like i was agreeing
largely after the bit you mentioned the
uh like chad's part
uh but i do agree with you that the two
like main tenets of the
like two of the major tenants that have
red pill is that they want a high value
man and they want
and they don't want a nice guy i think
they're like two major tenants but like
i did i disagree to some extent with the
uh chad argument i think that's more so
in the black bill
would you say better bachelor is
blackpill
i'm not hugely familiar with his content
but um
i know a couple of other people have uh
referenced
him in other interviews and by the
sounds of it he sounds
like i think i think he's mgtow i'm not
entirely sure i don't watch his content
but i've heard that he's mgtow or
something like that
oh is that not the same thing as red
pill yeah yeah it is it's like
there's different branches like of the
red hill like mgtow's slightly more in
line with
blackpill as compared with like pua like
have you heard of pua
uh picked up artists yeah yeah so that's
like more strongly tied to the red pill
i would say in in the respect that it's
trying to teach men to become a high
value man and not being the nice guy so
learning all of these different uh
techniques um like
what what techniques like would you say
that these red pill guys uh
give advice like they give to men in
order to become a high value man
oh my gosh i heard the worst one the
other day it was
from fresh and fit and he said to tell a
girl
if if you're on a date with a girl and
you take her back to your place
and she says i don't want to sleep with
you say okay
i need you to leave so i can like call
another girl basically
like if you're not gonna have sex with
me i'm gonna call someone else who will
really so so what are your thoughts on
that
what are my thoughts yeah i mean i
should i just thought it was rude i mean
you could tell her to leave if you want
that's
fine if you don't if that's what you
want but i don't think that's gonna work
for a guy that's a four or a three
she'll probably just be like okay
see that's a very like interesting funny
point that
you just raised that because i think
that is exactly where the black bill
steps in
that all of these so-called techniques
like honestly if they
if a chad did that if an eight out of 10
you know did the i'm gonna talk to
somebody else
technique it most likely will work for
him i would say because
the woman is going to want to chase him
rather than the other way around
but if a three out of 10 pulls the exact
same move then
uh like i think that's where the black
people steps here they just say yeah
she's just gonna look back and laugh she
could be like i'm
above you anyway like there's there's no
point in doing that
yeah and i don't think you could and
that's where i disagree that's why i
liked your channel so much
honestly because you kind of you don't
sorry i i missed a hole at that point um
you cut out like right
before you okay um so you don't you
don't really give advice on your channel
but that's why i liked your channel
was because you you i would imagine if
you were to give advice you'd probably
give different advice to different
people depending on where they stand
yeah
100 like i think so far i'm surprised
you view that as a positive because i'll
actually say that's one of my biggest
criticisms
uh so far that people say my channel is
focused on
diagnosing issues and is always quick to
point out the problem
but it's never there to point out the
solution but i think
like i've had my channel for about six
seven months now
and so far i've just been focusing on
like diagnosing the issues within the
dating market and i think
hopefully more so like in the future i'm
going to be uh
focusing more on the potential solutions
based on your
looks level as well like because as you
said like i'll give different pieces of
advice for
different people based on their like
ranking or on the uh
on the look scale so obviously like if a
man is sub five then he's gonna have
completely different
potential solutions to a man who is
struggling with dating if he's a
five to seven well and that's what i
said on one of my channels like
because the red pill says don't ever
date a single mother don't ever date a
single mother or a girl with a high body
count
and you know i i could totally see if
you have the option to not but some guys
don't
have that those options
so if a guy's like a two or three and
there's no way in hell he can ever get
to be a five
um i mean he could one option is to you
know try to get to be a five and see if
you can pull like a four
maybe but if you're a two to three
you're not very motivated
what what are you gonna like it might
say that it's better to reduce his
standards and take the options he has
like
such as the single mothers or uh
women women with women with high counts
i would say it depends what you want
um some guys are okay being alone
forever if that's what you want go do
that
so going like the so-called mgtow route
you know just
abstain from dating all together
um i guess what what bothers me more is
they seem to think they have an
abundance of
options where they can demand this this
this this from a girl and i'm just
trying to be
real where you might not like you might
not be like
like that might be the only option you
have sorry
i'm so glad you said that you're going
to get so much love you're going to get
so much love from the comments now that
you just
you just read that comment well but it's
the same thing with women
right like if a girl's a four and she's
demanding eight level
like she might want this this this this
and that but if she can't get that
okay she might have to like sacrifice on
the body or the height or whatever it
is but yeah and but like and the black
and the the red pill wants to like
demonize women for like
uh maybe not demonize and i understand
it's frustrating because a lot of women
don't know what level they're on and i
could say like that delusion is probably
frustrating but
at the end of the day if guys had like a
virgin model that wanted them
they would probably pick that but at the
end of the day people are people
they're not perfect you know everyone
wants the best option on both sides
women just have the leverage most of the
time
but you have to like evaluate your
standards based on
your own position uh like in the
hierarchy
yes yes yeah i agree that to
like a significant extent uh going back
to answering your question
uh you asked me like what i believe the
black pill is this is the way i put it
from now on but i think the black bill
has
three key pillars like three key tenets
number one is looks like just
looks it's just one word the first
pillar is just looks that
looks is the biggest uh factor for a
man's dating success like
above all else to a significant extent
and when i'm talking about looks i'm
talking about um
like a few different things so height
number one having a good face good
jawline good eyes
um to some extent body i still believe
that like high body fat is a big killer
for men
um and like having good hair
good hairline so you can't be balding
having a large
like load of inches if you're not i'm
mean that's i'm trying to like say it
play it safe
for the youtube algorithm and being
young
and also unfortunately uh your ethnicity
as well
okay mostly those things so that's the
first point just
just looks like i'm mostly referring to
genetics for that
and the second pillar is inflexibility
and this is closely like tied to the
first one so it's mostly things that you
can't change
but you can't unless you're
significantly higher body fat
it's almost impossible or literally
impossible without surgery to coat
sorry you just cut out again i don't
know where it cuts off
i don't you said body fat that's where i
was at yeah yeah so
yeah so like it's almost impossible for
a man of high body fat to
unless he's high body fat to go from a
three to an eight it's almost impossible
without surgery or
losing a significant weight of his high
body fat
okay yeah and the last point
is women are in agreement of the things
that they find attractive
so like they all find the similar so
looks aren't subjective there is no
like very minimal subjectivity like 95
of tinder likes go to the top 50 of men
so
that implicitly shows that uh women like
are in agreement of the
people that they find attractive so they
have certain requirements
based on a man's heights based on a
man's face based on
all the other different factors going
into romance looks like they're all
mostly to the most part 95 is
based based on these objective features
that we look out for
and then like the last five to ten
percent maybe is subjective
like preference for eye color and et
cetera
so like they're my three points uh like
the main pillars of the black wheel
looks
inflexibility and like agreeability
from what universe that universality
sorry that's a better way
for the black people so you think it's
95
um looks for like what women look for
again like it goes back to the argument
i was saying earlier that it changes
with age
so for teenagers it may as well be 95
looks but for people in the
for men like in their mid to low 20s
it's probably like closer to
60 to 70 and then other things such as
money status and
social skills things like that come into
play and then once
once men reach like 13 onwards then i'd
probably say
still about 55 60 looks and then
other factors such as status come like
have a bit
more of a greater percentage do you
think that people can improve their
social skills that much
that's interesting like there's
arguments both for and against i would
say it's definitely more plastic than
factors such as height and face
obviously
however i think you're still limited in
the
degree that you can improve your social
skills but it's definitely more plastic
than
other things but even then have you
realistically seen
guys that you know like they went from a
really shy introverted guy
in high school and then all of a sudden
in their mid 25s they
like ballooned into this really
charismatic uh outgoing person i just
don't really see that often
yeah no that's that's what i would say
too like maybe if you're a five in terms
of charisma
you can maybe get to like a six maybe a
seven if like you really put the time in
but i don't see
people making like a five to like a ten
changes
yeah yeah i think the same similar thing
um
anyway unless there was like any other
points she wanted to make um i think
it's been a really
really good call actually like one of
the actually better ones compared to
what i've
had recently unless there was any other
points you wanted to make um i'm happy
to end it here
no that's totally fine thanks for coming
on oh
thanks a lot yeah i've really enjoyed
this call hopefully i'll speak to you
soon
okay cool